economía de este 23 de octubre
bienvenidos y bienvenida a la
especialista económica daniel hablando
un ramírez daniela buenas noches hoy se
resolvió el dilema de si una hamburguesa
vegetariana se puede llamar así
hamburguesa en europa a la noche que
dice que sí o que no bueno sé que son
deliciosos pero tú informado por favor
es mire el parlamento europeo aprobó
este viernes la reforma política
agrícola común eso no es más que el
documento que regulará el campo europeo
entre 2023 y 2027 y los empresarios del
sector cárnico habían pedido que
productos como la hamburguesa salchicha
o filete se llamaran así solamente
cuando tuvieran carne animal pero les
negaron la razón la decisión fue
calificada por los propios
parlamentarios como una derrota para el
sector cárnico si hubieran decidido lo
contrario los 27 estados miembros
hubieran tenido que ponerse a buscar
nombres para cada uno de estos alimentos
pero no todo fue victoria para los
ecologistas la unión europea impidió el
uso de referencias como similar a la
leche para comparar productos lácteos
que no contienen ingredientes
lácteos por ejemplo mantequilla de soja
o leche de almendra aunque este punto en
particular debe entrar a negociarse con
cada país muy bien daniela vámonos a
sudamérica y es que el gobierno
argentino dice que no devaluará su
moneda así después no importa cuántas
medidas se pongan en marcha en argentina
pero el dólar paralelo sigue siendo
mucho más costoso que el dólar oficial y
el peso está en niveles históricamente
bajos eso ha hecho pensar que el
gobierno de alberto fernández debería
devaluar artificialmente la moneda sin
embargo hoy el ministro de economía
martín guzmán lo descartó por completo
el dólar oficial es el que se tranza en
el banco de la nación hace un año valía
61 pesos y hoy está en 83 y el dólar
blue o paralelo el que se vende en el
mercado informal ya se acerca a los 190
pesos cuando hace un año estaba a menos
de 70 como vemos en la gráfica eso
significa que la brecha entre el uno y
el otro es cada vez más
nos vamos a reino unido y es que ya
firmó su primer acuerdo comercial post
break set si estás considerada la puerta
de entrada de gran bretaña hacia el
pacífico a partir de enero próximo
cuando entra en plena vigencia el break
sit
este acuerdo firmado entre reino unido y
japón- reduce de forma progresiva los
aranceles británicos sobre la
importación de automotores japoneses
hasta eliminarlos en 2026 también
permite que un 99 por ciento de las
exportaciones británicas hacia la
tercera economía mundial no tenga
aranceles justamente hoy alan están
sentados en londres los negociadores del
acuerdo postor break sheet y en japón
aprovecharon para echarle un indirectas
a bruselas se solía decir que un reino
unido- independiente no podría llegar a
un acuerdo comercial importante o que
tardaría años en concluirlo pero hoy se
demostró que los detractores estaban muy
equivocados con este innovador acuerdo
muy al estilo británico que se negoció
en un tiempo récord para contar me
adelantaba con otro tema interesante
daniela las acciones del principal
productor de tequila del mundo se
dispararon
porque jose a cuerpo le suena si es así
bueno subieron casi un 7 por ciento de
sus acciones hoy en la bolsa de méxico
luego de presentar un sólido balance en
el tercer trimestre las ventas en el
período subieron 26 por ciento en
volumen en total se vendieron 66
millones de cajas de 9 litros en apenas
tres meses los ingresos por estas ventas
aumentaron en casi un 50 por ciento
frente al mismo trimestre del año pasado
y a las utilidades les fue mucho mejor
casi se triplicaron en canadá es donde
más está creciendo el consumo de esta
bebida alcohólica muy bien daniela vamos
con los indicadores económicos de esta
jornada oeste del cerro en terreno mixto
todos muy concentrados en las elecciones
y en un paquete de estímulos que nada
que se concreta las bolsas europeas
subieron pero no pudieron compensar las
grandes pérdidas del miércoles y jueves
y terminan la semana en rojo y en
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
cerró a la baja pero subió más del 3 por
ciento durante la semana y nos vamos con
la cifra del día sólo 114 millones de
que entregó en premio récord el
regulador de valores de eeuu al
denunciante de un fraude bursátil esa
persona con su información secreta ayudó
a dos grandes investigaciones y la tengo
este dato alan los premios a los
denunciantes pueden oscilar entre el 10
y el 30 por ciento del dinero que se
recaude cuando la multa supera el millón
de dólares es buen negocio muy bien
daniela muy de acuerdo gracias por el
recorrido económico y ustedes por su
compañía vea más mucho más en france 24
[Música]